♪ ♪
- COME NOW, MARY MAGDALENE.
STAND AND BE FORGIVEN
FOR YOUR SINS.
- BUT, JESUS,
HOW CAN I BE FORGIVEN?
I'M A PROSTITUTE.
- NO, CHILD.
YOU WERE A PROSTITUTE.
THAT LIFE IS BEHIND YOU NOW.
- MARY MAGDALENE!
WHERE YOU AT, BITCH?
- OH, NO, JESUS.
I THINK IT'S MY PIMP.
I THINK HE FOUND ME.
- THERE YOU ARE!
MAN, TOOK ME FOREVER
TO FIND YO ASS!
I BEEN LOOKIN'
ALL OVER FOR YOU!
YOU KNOW HOW MANY BITCHES
NAMED MARY THERE ARE UP IN HERE?
NOW GET YOUR ASS
IN THAT CARAVAN!
- NO!
NO, I'M NOT
GOING WITH YOU, GALILEROY.
I'M GONNA
STAY HERE WITH JESUS.
- WHAT THE FLIP IS THIS?
YOU WASHING
THIS [bleep] FEET?
- MAYBE.
- WELL, I TAUGHT YOU THAT!
I RESCUED YOU
FROM THAT FISHING VILLAGE,
I CLEANED YOU UP
AND GOT YOU OUT TO WORK,
AND NOW THIS IS
HOW YOU REPAY ME?
YOU GO OUT AND GET YOURSELF
ANOTHER PIMP?
HELL, NO, BROTHA,
SHE'S MINE.
- I DON'T THINK
YOU UNDERSTAND.
SHE'S NOT GOING WITH YOU.
- WELL, I CAN'T AFFORD
TO LOSE HER.
I ALREADY LOST THREE BITCHES
TO LEPROSY, ALL RIGHT?
ALL I GOT LEFT IS MARY,
A CRIPPLE, AND TWO BLIND CHICKS,
WHO--
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
THEY GET REQUESTED A LOT.
DON'T ASK ME HOW THAT WORKS.
- GET OUTTA HERE!
I'M NOT GOING WITH YOU,
GALILEROY.
I'M STAYING HERE WITH JESUS,
AND I'M WARNING YOU,
JESUS HAS, LIKE,
12 FOLLOWERS.
TELL HIM.
- OH, 12?
PSSH. OKAY, ALL RIGHT, SO THIS
MOTHER[bleep] A SERIOUS PIMP.
- NO, MY FRIEND.
YOU'RE CONFUSED.
IT'S 12 MEN.
- UH, WHAT--
WHAT, YOU A GAY PIMP?
- I'M NOT A PIMP.
I'M A CARPENTER.
- CARPENTER?
[scoffs]
THEN WHY DOES YOUR HOUSE
LOOK LIKE [bleep]?
- I'VE BEEN BUSY
WITH NON-CARPENTRY WORK.
- OKAY, THAT'S IT.
BITCH, PACK YOUR [bleep].
GET IN THE CARAVAN
AND MAKE ME SOME MONEY.
- NO! AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY STUFF TO PACK.
JESUS SAYS
WE DON'T NEED THINGS.
- WHAT THE--
- IS THIS ALL ABOUT MONEY?
- HELL, YEAH,
IT'S ALL ABOUT MONEY, BROTHA.
- I HAVE A SAYING.
IT GOES LIKE THIS.
- OH, YOU'RE GONNA LOVE THIS.
- SHUT UP.
- IT'S EASIER FOR A CAMEL TO
PASS THROUGH THE EYE OF A NEEDLE
THAN FOR A RICH MAN
TO ENTER THE KINGDOM OF GOD.
- WHEW.
- OH, YEAH?
WELL, I GOT A SAYING TOO.
IT'S EAS--YOU KNOW,
WHY DON'T YOU PASS YOUR OWN--
PASS YOUR ASS
THROUGH THE NEED--
MAN, [bleep] YOU, MAN.
COME ON!
- THE GIRL STAYS.
- WHAT? [grunts]
- OH!
[heavenly music plays]
♪ ♪
- MOTHER[bleep],
I SLAP YOU,
AND YOU WANT ME
TO HIT YOU ON THE OTHER CHEEK?
THAT AIN'T GANGSTA.
THIS [bleep] IS CRAZY.
YOU CAN HAVE HIM.
I'M DONE.
- WAIT, FRIEND.
[opera music plays]
SO YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE
NO HARD FEELINGS,
WOULD YOU CARE
TO JOIN US FOR DINNER?
- WHAT Y'ALL HAVIN'?
- [operatic singing]
♪ ♪